there's this funny effect where
uh just looking at different fields
where people discover parallels
they'll they'll prove something it'll be
a totally new result and then somebody
later realizes this was already done 30
years ago and another discipline
in another way and it's really
interesting
uh we did this offline another
illustration he showed to me
it's interesting to see the different
perspectives
on a problem it kind of points like
there's just like very few novel ideas
that everything else that most of us are
just looking at different perspective on
the same idea
and it makes you wonder this this uh
this old silly question
that i have to ask you is uh do you
think
mathematics is uh discovered or invented
do you think we're creating
a new idea we're building a set of
knowledge
that's that's distinct from reality
or are we actually like it's or is math
almost like a shovel where we're digging
to
like this core set of truths that are oh
that
that were always there all along so i
personally feel like it's discovered
but that's also because i guess the way
that i like to choose what questions to
work on
are questions that maybe we'll get to
learn something about
why is this hard i mean i'm often
attracted to questions that
look simple but are hard right and what
could you possibly learn from that sort
of like probably the attraction of
vermont's last theorem
as you mentioned simple statement why is
it so hard so i'm more on the
discovered side and i also feel like if
we ever ran into an intelligent
other species in the universe
probably if we compared notes there
might be some similarities between
both of us realizing that pi is
important because
you might say why why humans do humans
like circles more than others i think
stars also like circles i think planets
like circles they're not perfect circles
but
nevertheless the concept of a circle is
just point and
constant distance doesn't get any
simpler than that
you